foreign
Chelsea welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking our call sure how
can we help
well speaking of things that you cannot
afford my husband and I bought a house
in August and we are having some buyer's
remorse and we're now wondering if we
should sell our house oh okay walk us
through what happened
well
um a few months after so we got married
in August and I said butterhouse
um and we we instantly had the buyer's
remorse because that was about the time
we got into Dave and baby steps and the
house is definitely not what he
recommends but then I also lost my job
so that was about a hundred thousand
dollar
um
pay cuts um
and we've been working with a financial
advisor and we've cut out everything and
we're on baby step two but we were
barely making ends meet and last night
we had to spend about ten thousand
dollars to save our puppy's life that we
didn't plan on
I'm so sorry you guys have been through
it
we have it's been a rough um our I mean
our mortgage is Now 52 is our total
income take home pay of take-home pay
yeah okay well and
um yeah so we we're debating selling our
house
um we think we have a maybe a little bit
of equity
um and just renting and starting fresh
but we didn't know if that was a
terrible idea so are you working again
what's your current income
I am um I took a job that I actually
really love but it's I'm making about 48
000 um it's a lot of commission based so
it has the potential to make a lot more
than what I was making but it'll
probably be about
six months to a year before I really
start seeing those commission checks
okay and what's your husband's income
um he we we own a gym so he brings home
it's kind of it's different since it's
self-employed but I probably around a
hundred thousand okay so let's say 150
000 household income before taxes
okay what other debt do you have
um we have 125 000 in debt most of it is
um we have car we sold our other
um we now have the ten thousand dollars
that we had to put on a credit card for
the dogs and then we have
um one other a couple other credit cards
a totals about six thousand dollars okay
now I'm assuming with this mortgage
payment you guys don't have a lot of
wiggle room at the end of each month to
even throw at the debt
you know we've cut out everything that
we can excuse me um please cut out
completely everything that we can so
it's we're actually we use every dollar
and when we do our budget we're about
negative 100 every month and we've just
kind of left out and that's what you
guys really dialing in the budget
yeah just between the debt payments the
mortgage and paying just straight up
bills I mean you're not doing any
frivolous spending it sounds like you've
played that game not we yeah we have
enough frivolous spending we've started
using cash to buy our groceries
um do you guys have any savings in the
bank or anything you could sell
um
other than our we're upside down in the
car that we do have which is why we
didn't sell it yet
um we had a thousand dollar savings that
is now gone as as of last night and no
no other savings what's your home worth
like would you pay for it and what's it
worth
um we paid 769 000 and two it's a new
development neighborhood and two other
houses in the neighborhood recently um
one recently sold and one is currently
on the market and once they're those
sold for about 8.50 to 915.
okay so and you said you have a little
bit of equity
we are well so we we only put down I I
don't mean I think we put down five
percent
um because it was my first home purchase
and we did a 30-year mortgage um
so our we owe 750 and we we're thinking
we can maybe sell it for 8.50 okay so
you might net a little bit of cash that
would help you start attacking this debt
but it's not like a silver bullet
no because now we got to pay rent and we
still have probably 75 grand worth of
debt to tackle
yes how
do you have a rinse in your area
compared with what you're paying now
we did we did that right before we
called you um we could probably rent
something for about three thousand
um so that would save us about 2200 a
month so your mortgage payment is 5200 a
month on a 30 year
yes man I gotta tell you Chelsea I I
hate telling folks to get out of their
house George that's a big move I
actually rarely tell people to sell the
house but this is one of those
situations where I wouldn't be able to
breathe if I were you she can't breathe
you can't we can't yeah
breathe I mean like it's you've cut down
your budget to nothing it's a skeleton
you're both working and I know there's
probably some months where the gym is
doing better than others but you don't
know that and you're on commission and
and here's the thing when you're on in
debt and you're working it changes the
way you work you've just got that that
crazed mentality so it's probably not
doing anything to help you in your job
right now
um do you know what I'm saying am I
right yeah you know you don't want to be
a desperate salesman you don't want to
be a desperate salesman um
I I hate to say it but something tells
me the moment that you break free of
this you're gonna exhale and you're
gonna be like oh
thank God we can breathe again
I would at least start the process reach
out to a realtor we have some great
Ramsey trusted Real Estate Pros you can
connect with at ramseysolutions.com and
to start the process see what the
Market's actually doing how much you
could get for the house and while you're
doing that I'm going to start working my
tail off to see if we can get some
traction and maybe have an ultimatum and
say hey if things aren't in a much
better place three or six months from
now where we can see the light at the
end of the tunnel we gotta sell this
house this is the monkey on our back
that's killing us okay and and here's
what here's here's another reason beyond
the money you guys are newlyweds you're
starting out life you don't want to
start out life
there's enough stuff that you're
learning being newly married right you
don't want this pile of debt just
making matters worse or making matters
stressful like that first year of
marriage is Tough Enough can I get it
amen George amen is it just me okay
I'm just saying I think that
I just think in the Long Haul it's going
to serve you serve you better and you'll
have a home that's a blessing and not a
burden and most of the time people have
done this they look back and go that was
the right move rarely do they go oh my
gosh if we wouldn't have sold her how it
could have been this much no one's
thinking about appreciation all you're
trying to do is survive in this state
and so it really does it will speed up
this process of helping you guys become
debt free much faster and then when you
go back to buy a house the right way
it's going to be a blessing in your life
instead of a curse that's right when you
save up 10 to 20 with no payments in the
world and probably more because it's you
know freaking Boston and homes that are
crazy expensive yeah and so crazy it may
be another five years before you guys
are homeowners and that's okay that's
all right but don't believe the lies
that everyone needs to jump into Home
Ownership it sounds like you had some
pressures in your life we're like hey
you're married now you got to get it
home what are you doing wasting money on
rent was that the narrative
um it was more like we had it was like I
said it was right before we got into
Dave and we had Justified it as we were
paying separately before we were living
together about 8 000 in rent he has this
three thousand line with five thousand
so this was saving money
five thousand dollars for rent wow yeah
Boston
um I do have a question because I've
heard that if I guess someone told me
once that if you sell your house before
two years you get some kind of fees for
that is that you will have capital gains
yes okay 15 right George
but for most it depends on your incomes
I'm guessing with your incomes it would
probably be
um it may it may count kind of just
extra income at that point if it's
because it's been under a year
yeah your income is it looks like if
your income is if your taxable income is
more than between 41 and 459 000 okay 15
percent
so I would also look into the tax
implications you it may just be a net
wash and that's okay we're not selling
this house to make a giant profit we're
doing it to get out from under this
giant payment and like you said it's
going to free up 2200 a month plus
that's borrowing nothing else goes wrong
with the house I mean what happens if
the HVAC goes out tomorrow right and
well luckily it's a it's a new
construction so we're you have a
one-year warranty yeah well why we're
talk while we're talking about fees or
things that might come up I gotta say
this right quick I gotta talk about this
dog right quick because when it comes to
these vet vet bills and and you just got
through something where you spent ten
thousand dollars
you need to put a cap on that because if
if Rover is still not doing so well and
something pops up later you've got to
have a cap on what you're going to spend
on this you can't continue to go into
debt for a pet
I'm sorry but you can't do it
sometimes it feels like dog ownership is
more expensive than homo I know I know I
just lost a lot of friends on that